-Donald Trump apparently stashed
highly classified documents
about the nuclear capabilities
of a foreign nation
at his country club
and reportedly bragged
to friends he had intelligence
about the French president's
sex life.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Before we get to the story
about a deeply
compromised ex-president
with various connections
to international criminals
and shady financial
entanglements
who apparently stole
highly classified documents
about nuclear capabilities
and left them lying around
the basement
of his fake marble golf lair --
you know,
normal politics stuff --
there's also been
an intense heat wave
happening in California
and much of the West right now.
Which, first of all, should be
yet another wake up call
to the imminent dangers
of climate change,
but it's also
one of those stories
that comes along every so often
that neatly captures
just how craven and ghoulish
the modern GOP
has become under Donald Trump.
You see, California Governor
Gavin Newsom
asked residents of the state
to conserve energy
for a few hours to avoid
blackouts,
and so far, it's worked.
Californians banded together
and kept the power grid
running without issue.
But then this mid-November
Jack-o-lantern
who sounds like Urkel
swallowed a kazoo
decided to chime in
on the whole thing
in a way that revealed
a complete lack of shame
and self-awareness
for no other reason
than he's apparently
just a glutton for humiliation.
-I love that Gavin Newsom was
wearing his fleece,
obviously in cool air
conditioning,
saying, "Let them eat cake.
Let them sweat.
You don't get air conditioning."
It's like John Kerry
who flies his private jet
all over the planet,
lecturing people
that you poor, gritty
working class
with dirt under
your fingernails,
you need to go
without an automobile.
You need to turn
your air conditioner off.
In fact, you need to just
stay home and eat worms.
-Now, if he has worms
on the brain,
it's probably because
there was one in the bottle
of the tequila he drank in
Cancun after he fled his state
while his constituents froze
in a deadly winter storm.
Do you guys remember that?
Is it bad?
Is it bad when your senator
looks like Harold Hill
trying to catch a train
out of town?
Now, aside from
the Cancun hypocrisy
from zombie Danny Zuko
over here,
I would also like to point out
that, unlike California,
Texas's deregulated power grid
actually did fail during that
deadly snowstorm in 2021,
and remains so fragile
that Texas officials
basically did the same thing
as California earlier this year.
Texas's grid operator urged
electricity conservation
as the heat wave
drove up demand.
In fact, the state's
power grid operator asked Texans
to turn up their thermostats
and postpone
running major appliances
between 2:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m.,
6 hours.
That's just enough time
to book a flight to Cancun
and then have your neighbors,
who apparently all hate you,
rat you out to
"The New York Times."
Remember that?
When Cruz invited his neighbors
to come to Cancun with him,
and instead, they immediately
called the newspapers
to complain about
how much of [bleep] he was.
Imagine how much
you have to dislike
someone to call
a newspaper about it.
I don't even know
how to call a newspaper.
What was that conversation?
"Man, Cruz stinks.
You gonna tweet about him?"
"No, I'm calling
the newspapers.
I want every single person
staying at a hotel
to hear about this."
Anyway, Cruz is just one of
the more noxious examples
of the GOP's many shameless
liars and Trump toadies.
There's also
Florida Senator Marco Rubio,
who has been one of Trump's
most vocal defenders
throughout the intensifying
criminal investigation
into all
the classified documents
Trump apparently
had stashed away
at his off-brand Marriott
for disbarred
personal injury lawyers.
Rubio had already dismissed
the investigation
as a storage issue last week,
and now he's complaining
about leaks to the media.
-If true, this "Washington Post"
report highly
classified documents
at Mar-a-Lago that only
a cabinet-level officer
or higher could even look at.
That doesn't seem like
the kind of thing
you should have in your
post-presidential desk drawer.
-Well, let's break this down.
First of all, again,
we really don't know,
'cause let's go back
and understand
that all of this information
is coming from one side
and one place,
and that is sources with
knowledge of the investigation.
Who are the sources with
knowledge of the investigation?
The FBI
and the Justice Department,
and they are leaking
to the media.
And the only reason
to leak to the media
is to influence
the narrative,
which tells you
this is being politicized,
which is doing damage
to the FBI,
the Justice Department,
to important institutions
to our country.
-What do you think
does more damage
to our country's institution?
Leaking information about
an investigation
of a great public interest,
or Donald Trump bringing
home national secrets
on his last day
at work like Henry Winkler
taking home the Fonzie jacket
when they wrapped "Happy Days"?
And I know the Fonzie jacket
is in the Smithsonian now,
but that's only after the Feds
raided Henry's house.
Oh. Oh, he seems sweet,
ol' Henry Winkler,
but he almost
never leaves a room
without a stolen prop
in his pocket.
[ Laughter ]
But you know, I just have to say
I'm so surprised to hear
Rubio change his tune
on the Trump document scandal,
because before this
recent revelation,
he was actually very vocal about
the importance of being careful
with classified information.
-Apparently, this is a level of
intelligence classification
that goes beyond top secret.
Now, am I wrong
in my reading of the law
that this would be
multiple felonies,
a felony in every case?
I mean, isn't this indictable?
-Yeah, this is very serious.
This is very serious.
Number one, obviously,
there's a legal element to it.
And again, we're going
to leave that to the FBI
and to the Justice Department.
Yeah, but moving forward,
there's legal issues here.
But let me just say, how can
the next commander in chief
be someone
who inappropriately stashes
highly classified information?
-And the risk of that is?
-The risk of that is that
we're giving opponents
of this government
or adversaries
insight into our thinking,
into our decision making,
and it provides
most certainly an advantage
in the national security realm.
-Thank you, Senator Rubio.
Honestly, it's just
so refreshing to hear
a Republican finally muster up
the courage to state the obvious
and take on Trump's
various abuses of power.
In fact, to celebrate
his honesty and consistency,
we had an ice cream cake made
just for him that says on it,
"Thank you for your bravery,
Senator Rubio --"
Oh, crap. I forgot we...
We had to turn off
the fridge all day
to conserve power.
Well, it's...
You guys, it's the thought.
It's the thought that counts.
Anyway,
congratulations to Marco Rubio
for showing the courage --
What's that?
The clips we showed
were from 2015 and 2016?
And he was talking about
Hillary Clinton's emails,
and we just edited out
the parts where he said her name
to demonstrate the shameless
hypocrisy and self-debasement
in service of Donald Trump?
Well, then, you know what?
I'm glad the cake melted!
We'll just give it to the crew.
Like, blend it up.
Tell them it's milkshakes.
And let them know it's my idea.
Put a note on it
that says it from me.
That'll finally tap the brakes
on their bullying.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
So Rubio, like the rest of them,
continues to brush this off
like it's no big deal,
despite the fact that Trump
apparently had
some of the government's
most closely guarded secrets
in his possession,
which we now know
included materials
about a foreign country's
nuclear capabilities.
-We're following some
breaking news
on the Justice Department
investigation to the documents
Donald Trump had stashed away.
"The Washington Post"
has just reported that,
"a document describing a foreign
government's military defenses,
including its
nuclear capabilities,
was found by FBI agents
who searched Donald Trump's
Mar-a-Lago residence."
The Post previously reported
that nuclear documents
were among those sought
by investigators.
-Also from "The Post" reporting,
some of the seized documents
detail top secret
U.S. operations
that are so closely guarded,
many senior national
security officials
are kept in the dark about them.
-Okay, but in fairness,
Trump was probably
also kept
in the dark about them.
Technically, I guess they had
to show him classified documents
when he was president,
but they probably distracted him
the same way you gave your kid
an iPad on an airplane
to shut him up.
"Alright, sir, here are those
nuclear documents
we are required
by law to show you.
But also we DVR'd Rudy's latest
appearance on Hannity for you.
You can watch that, or an
episode of 'Paw Patrol'."
"Maybe. We do --
We do love 'Paw Patrol.'
We love law and order.
We love paws and laws and order.
Plus, Rudy does kind of remind
me of Wally the Walrus."
[ Laughter ]
Well, let's just take
a step back
and let it soak in
how insane this is.
The president just had a bunch
of highly classified materials
lying around the basement
of his country club
about extremely
sensitive global affairs
that affect the safety and
security of the entire world.
And no, I'm not talking about
Harry Styles
spitting on Chris Pine,
although, although I will say
this right here is one of those
extremely rare pop culture
moments where I do wish
Trump had his Twitter back,
just for a minute,
so we could see what would
almost certainly be a psychotic
and likely very funny take
on the whole thing.
"Many people are saying,
Harry No-Styles spit
(drooled?) on one of our
great American Chris's
at the Venus Film Festival.
Could it have been
gum or mint (Tik Tak)?
Lots of germs.
Not nice!
Sleepy Joe should act!
#WheresHunterslaptop
[ Applause ]
I would say the man knew how
to tweet, but he clearly didn't,
and that's what
made it so special.
I do think,
all things considered,
it's probably not ideal
that an ex-president
with a bunch of corrupt
foreign entanglements
to mobsters and dictators,
not to mention various
indicted henchmen,
had a bunch of classified
information about weapons
that could eliminate
all life on earth
just lying around
his country club
where spies or Botox salesmen
could just easily find them.
But don't you worry.
Trump's very normal son, Eric,
would like to assure us,
contrary to the photo
the Justice Department released
as part of its affidavit
in the case,
Trump kept his country club
very organized.
-You literally have the FBI
spending more time
leaking stuff to the press.
I mean, these pictures --
you think my father happened
to just leave documents
all over his office floor?
-No, I think when
the FBI found them,
they laid them out
and took a picture of them.
I also don't think drug dealers
keep all their money and cocaine
neatly stacked on one table.
[ Laughter ]
"Hey, you sure we shouldn't hide
this stuff somewhere, boss?"
"Nah, I like the way
it brings the room together.
Yeah, make them neat.
Make all the money neat."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I love how these guys
suddenly complain about leaks
now, after supporting
Donald Trump,
arguably the biggest and
messiest gossip on the planet.
He reportedly bragged to
some of his closest associates,
both during and after his time
in the White House,
that he knew illicit details
about the love life
of French President
Emmanuel Macron.
I'm sorry,
you think it's scandalous
that a French politician
had an illicit love life?
You know what would be
way more scandalous?
A French politician
with a boring love life.
You think an illicit love life
would be bad for
Emmanuel Macron?
I'm pretty sure
his official campaign slogan
was Macron a trois?
[ Laughter ]
There's no simpler,
more straightforward example
of how brazen and shameless
the Republican Party
has become in its acceptance
of lawbreaking
and abuses of power
when it comes to Donald Trump.
They will support or apologize
for anything he does,
no matter how egregious,
because they are fully in thrall
to his authoritarian cult.
When it comes to Trump,
guys like Ted Cruz
and Marco Rubio
have the spines of...
-Worms.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look"!
♪♪
God's Love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year to
men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS, cancer
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.